[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous savez comment se
construit le psychisme de l'être humain
et bien au départ l'enfant n'existe pas
ou plutôt il n'a pas conscience
d'exister
le psychisme va passer par plusieurs
étapes pour construire son enveloppe
ainsi de 0 à 3 mois c'est la fusion
l'indifférenciation l'enfant n'a pas
conscience d'exister en tant que tel il
est le monde autant que le monde est lui
un peu comme son prolongement il est la
mer autant que la mère et lui et c'est
grâce à un cadre de maternage
bienveillant le protégeant de
désillusions trop précoce qu'il va
commencer à se différencier et c'est
vers le troisième mois que l'enfant va
manifester son premier contact avec
l'extérieur
le sourire puis dans la deuxième étape
et jusqu'au douzième mois grâce le plus
naturellement et le plus souvent à la
présence d'un père comme tiers
séparateur entre la mère et l'enfant
l'enfant va mesurer un écart entre ses
besoins et la satisfaction de ses
besoins
il va alors expérimenter la frustration
le manque
il va prendre ainsi conscience de sa
dépendance à l'autre c'est ce qu'on
appelle l' angoisse du 8ème mois
c'est le deuxième organisateurs
psychique après le sourire
les preuves de cette étape pour l'enfant
et d'accepter que l'autre que le cadre
que ses parents sont indispensables à sa
survie
et donc qu'ils ont un pouvoir sur lui
dans cette étape le cadre
les parents ont pour rôle non pour
fonction comme disait winnicott d'être
suffisamment bon c'est à dire ni trop
proches ni trop loin de la satisfaction
des besoins de l'enfant puis c'est vers
le 15e -
que va s'opérer le troisième et dernier
organisateur de fille chic le nom la
capacité à dire non
la capacité à résister à l'autre en
s'affirmant d'abord au travers de la
rétention des sel puis par extension à
d'autres refus l'enfant qui a donc
mesuré sa dépendance à l'autre va aussi
commencer à mesurer qu'il a un pouvoir
de satisfaction et de frustration sur
l'autre puis entre 3 et 7 ans environ
c'est la face du complexe d'oedipe et
sans dépassement va permettre
l'intégration de ce qu'on appelle un
authentique sur moi c'est l'intégration
de de l'interdît des limites
puis de 7 à 12 ans environ c'est la
phase de latence
c'est une phase de structuration
silencieuse une phase 2 de digestion
lente
on peut dire où les pulsions et les
conflits internes sont sont mis en
suspens et l'énergie psychique est dédié
plus au développement culturel social au
développement de la pensée logique et
tout ça pour arriver à la puberté à
l'adolescence véritable ligne d'arrivée
de la construction psychoaffective du
sujet sont dans cette phase que certains
connaissent peut-être en tout cas on est
tous passé on résiste aux cadres on
s'affirme l'identité du psychisme
l'identité de l'être humain se construit
différents et ressemblant à l'autre
ainsi en plusieurs étapes
le nourrisson est devenu un sujet il
s'est différencié de l'autre il a appris
à il a appris à supporter les limites
la frustration il s'est construit sa
propre identité
il est capable de rentrer dans le monde
et d'avoir sa propre perception du monde
et pour cela
en plus de ses ressources internes
l'individu a eu besoin de rencontrer des
cadres signifiant départ en signifiant
suffisamment bienveillant porter d'amour
porteurs de limite est donc porteur de
sens
ok alors retenons cela et faisons un
parallèle l'adulte a besoin à des
besoins des besoins qu'il doit
satisfaire pour pour pour maintenir sa
santé mentale pour maintenir son
équilibre psychique
on peut faire référence à la théorie
occidentale de maslow que certains
reconnaissent et on peut évoquer des
besoins de des besoins physiologiques
des besoins de sécurité de protection
des besoin d'amour d'appartenance des
besoins des steam de soi de réalisation
de soi et malgré la prétention de
l'homme moderne à se vouloir
autosuffisant nous avons besoin des
cadres qui nous entoure pour répondre à
ses besoins
et oui comme l'enfant l'adulte a besoin
de sécurité
l'adulte a besoin de sentir un
environnement suffisamment stables
suffisamment fiable suffisamment
prévisible le protégeant de désillusions
trop violente
et oui comme l'adulte l'enfant comme
lendemain al'inverse comme l'enfant
l'adulte a besoin de sentir qu'il fait
partie d'un tout qu'il fait partie d'un
ensemble en un ensemble où il a une
place où il est accepté et oui comme
l'enfant dans la phase du nombre
d'adultes a besoin de sentir qu'il a un
pouvoir un pouvoir d'action de décision
sur son existence et sur son
environnement
alors oui j'ai besoin du cadre qui
m'entourent mais j'ai besoin d'y
résister et c'est peut-être là le défi
le challenge de l'être humain que de
trouver cette juste posture entre
accepter tout et résister à tous si
j'accepte tout de mon environnement de
mon cadre des autres si je ne résiste
jamais jeu
n'existe pas ou alors complètement
moulée dans les limites de l'autre
complètement fondu dans les attentes de
l'autre
résister c'est un acte d'existence
d'autonomisation de survie mais si je
résiste à tous je m'isole je me croient
tout puissants
je ne me remets pas en question je
refuse toutes les contraintes de mon
environnement
oui c'est peut-être là un de nos défis
résister pour exister unique soit mais
tout en restant dans le cadre afin de le
faire s'est levé alors je me demande
souvent où nous en sommes dans notre
monde moderne où nous bousculons toutes
les limites de nos cadres avons-nous cru
sincèrement avant nous cru qu'en
élargissant le cadre des possibles
avons-nous cru qu'en privant l'être
humain de limites il allait être plus
heureux aujourd'hui
tout fonctionne dans le plus vite le
plus fort le plus performant le plus le
plus et plus encore et pourtant le sujet
moderne déprime pourquoi ça il ne le
comprend pas toujours
nous ne comprenons pas toujours qu'à
voir la bouche pleine avant même d'avoir
eu le temps d'avoir faim nous fait
perdre le sens de notre existence nous
nous sommes rendus insatiable à force de
repousser les limites des possibles est
aujourd'hui l'être humain j'ai
l'impression que l'être humain confins
ses désirs avec ses besoins et pense
qu'il doit réaliser ses désirs coûte que
coûte
mais c'est vrai que ça prête à confusion
parce que comment comment l'être humain
comment nous pourrions accepter de
frustrer certains de nos désirs alors
que nous sommes les témoins directs que
l'impossible est possible
nous sommes les témoins directs
qu'aujourd'hui on peut envoyer des
hommes dans l'espace
accédant à l'infiniment grand
aujourd'hui on peut courir le 100 m en
moins de dix secondes accédants l
infiniment rapide
aujourd'hui on isole des séquences adn
accédant l infiniment petit et
aujourd'hui on peut parler on peut voir
quelqu'un sur un écran qui habite à
20000 km accédants alain infiniment
accessible et aujourd'hui l'être humain
moderne doit accepter les limites doit
accepter de faire avec sa frustration
alors que comme on l'a vu dans les
étapes de la construction psycho
affectif de l'enfant
la frustration n'est pas quelque chose
que l'on apprend instinctivement les
hommes incarcérés avec lesquels je suis
amené à travailler en tant que
psychologue sont des auteurs de violence
des hauteurs de passage à l'acte violent
comme on dit et pour moi ce sont des
exemples un type de psychisme qui n'ont
pas rencontré de cadre suffisamment
signifiant suffisamment bienveillant
limitant porteur de sens est d'ailleurs
le cadre carcéral lorsqu'il lorsqu'il ne
s'opère que sur un versant punitif n'est
pour moi qu'une énième répétition d'une
boucle de la rencontre avec un cadre
défaillant pas suffisamment signifiant
ok mais je pense qu'il est il n'est pas
nécessaire d'aller jusqu'en prison pour
constater l'impact d'un cadre défaillant
sur nous individus par exemple on va
prendre un individu français il pourrait
dire objectivement je fais partie de
l'univers
je fais partie de la planète terre je
fais partie de l'humanité je fais partie
de la morale je fais partie de la france
je fais partie de l'état français je
fais partie de la justice française je
fais partie de l'entreprise pour
laquelle je travaille je fais partie de
mon cercle d'amis
je fais partie de ma famille je fais
partie de la gente féminine ou encore de
la gente masculine
oui ils pourraient dire cela mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il pourrait aussi
dire je fais partie de l'univers mais
aujourd'hui nous sommes devenus
tellement performant qu'on a défini
qu'il n'y avait peut-être pas de bord à
cet univers finalement c'est
complètement abstrait pour moi je ne
c'est pas comment le situer ça n'a pas
de sens oui je fais partie de la planète
terre mais aujourd'hui épuisée et parma
maltraitance elle est en train de me
signifier que bientôt elle ne pourra
plus me nourrir oui je fais partie de
l'humanité
mais est-ce que c'est sécurisant de
faire partie de l'humanité quand on
constate que l'être humain peut se
supprimer lui même oui je fais partie de
la morale mais aujourd'hui j'ai un peu
l'impression qu'on n'a pas toujours tous
la même morale oui je fais partie de la
france mais aujourd'hui on parle
d'europe de plus grand ensemble et
aujourd'hui encore une fois cet autre un
peu trop abstrait je ne sais pas aussi
dessus et je ne sais pas quelle est ma
place
oui je fais partie de l'état français ou
de la justice française mais aujourd'hui
avec la pléthore de jurisprudence je ne
sais plus quel sont les limites du droit
oui je fais partie de l'entreprise pour
laquelle je travaille mais aujourd'hui
je ne me sens pas compris par mes
managers
je me méfie de mes collègues et je
m'évertue à faire du bon boulot pour ne
pas être rejetés du groupe oui je fais
partie de mon cercle d'amis c'est vrai
mais aujourd'hui quand on se rencontre
j'ai l'impression qu'on se rate trop
pris par les autres cercles dans les
autres préoccupations et on est juste
envie de déverser notre mal être dans
quelques uns oui je fais partie de ma
famille est aujourd'hui c'est quoi la
famille avec toutes les formes
particulières qu'elle prend je ne sais
plus trop bien quel est le sens des
rôles de chacun oui je fais partie de la
gente féminine ou de la gente masculine
mais aujourd'hui je n'arrive plus à
définir ce qui est spécifique à l'homme
est spécifique à la femme nous êtres
humains avons besoin de cadres avons
besoin de cadres signifiant vous l'avez
compris suffisamment bienveillant
suffisamment limitant porteur de sens
afin que nous nous y construisions et
que nous existions en tant que tel et
afin de le faire évoluer
aujourd'hui nous bousculons beaucoup de
repères ce qui amène à cette angoisse
latente de perte de repères mais
n'oublions pas une dernière chose c'est
que la vie
et fait d'infini changement c'est
inhérent est essentielle mais nous
sommes des créateurs de ces changements
nous sommes les créateurs du cadre dans
lequel nous évoluons dans le cadre dans
lequel nous allons évoluer demain
devenons des acteurs responsables est
concerné par les changements que nous
créons devenant départ en devenant des
parents responsables et concernés par
nos enfants en leur apportant de l'amour
des limites du sens exprimons-nous de
manière authentique les uns aux autres
qu'on se ressemble au nom peu importe
alors ce soir j'ai de la gratitude
j'ai gardé la gratitude envers vous
envers nous parce que au travers de tedx
ensemble et chacun à la place qu'il
prend
nous créons un sens un sens favorable à
l'évolution de nos individualités et un
sens favorable à l'évolution de
l'ensemble formé par chacun d'entre nous
merci
[Applaudissements]